all right I deliberately separated out
this particular portion of Donald
Trump's latest unhinged speech that he
gave uh or statement to the camera not
really a speech kind of more just a
video I don't even know what to call it
at this point it's how he's
communicating with his so-called
followers I wanted to separate it out
because there's a much bigger story
behind it that's building uh among the
Republican party at the top of the show
I told you that there are many DeSantis
potential Mega donors who are furious
with DeSantis and getting away from him
but there's another movement that's
going on there's a movement that's going
on from within the Trump Camp to pound
and Crush DeSantis so badly now before
he even announces with the goal of
getting DeSantis to not even try wait
till 2028 or forget about it all
together is sort of the idea the right
wing Washington Times reports DeSantis
has Trump campaign's foot on his throat
seen as true threat to ex-presidents
2024 hopes and the idea of what's going
on here is that Trump on some level does
worry that if DeSantis did get into the
race
doesn't mean DeSantis would win but it
would be a fight that maybe Donald Trump
doesn't want to have and so the idea is
maybe Trump can get DeSantis to not even
get involved in this race altogether
and this brings us to this particular
moment from the speech from the video I
don't know why I keep calling it a
speech from the video that Donald Trump
published yesterday
where he just ranted and raved about the
Santa's poll numbers and this is
considered part of the effort to prevent
the contested primary Trump's still
winning by 20 in most polls but what
would be a contested primary and instead
opened the door for Trump to face off
against twos threes and fours as we call
them people polling two three and four
percent and have a much easier path to
the Republican nomination take a listen
to this getting lots of job requests
from people currently working for
Ron's poll numbers are dropping so fast
and furious that many people are
speculating
he's not going to run
he just hired Kiss of Death Jethro he's
a kiss of death I can tell you a lot of
the people that we defeated who were
represented by jeffrow Kiss of Death
who dropped young Kim you know who young
Kim is
to see if he can help
and he's going to help Ron but I don't
think he's going to help him much
because I'm leading in Texas by 42
points Iowa and New Hampshire by a lot
overall by close to 40 and by 10 against
the scammer Joe bidening okay so Trump
is not wrong Trump is genuinely polling
really really well uh in the Republican
primary and if you look at just the
trends this is real clear politics is a
chart of the trends I'll describe to you
what's going on you see a purple line
which is Trump and you see a green line
which is DeSantis and you do indeed see
that starting around March 11th and
accelerating dramatically around March
27th Donald Trump has gained
significantly in the Republican primary
polls and Ron DeSantis has started to
decline significantly and the decline
doesn't seem to be stopping right now I
already spoke with you earlier in the
show show there's a number of different
reasons that this is going on there's a
Washington Post article after
high-flying start DeSantis hits
stumbling blocks on the road to 2024
this article does mention the Republican
Mega donors that are moving away from
Ron DeSantis this mentions that many
Republicans aren't thrilled with the
six-week abortion ban again it's
potential Mega donors maybe not because
they personally are pro-choice but they
recognize the direction that the country
is and continues to has been moving and
continues to move on that issue they uh
believe that the sandis is making
unforced errors which include not only
signing that abortion ban but having to
clarify the comments on Ukraine being a
territorial dispute as I mentioned he's
striking Republicans as distant in
personal interactions and on and on and
on but he's still in second place so
there is now sort of this overt it's no
longer it's no longer a secret I don't
know that it ever was but it's no longer
a secret that Trump would like to knock
out DeSantis and get him not to even run
is that likely to happen
there's two different perspectives on
this perspective number one
is even if you're only polling 30 or
what was it exactly in that real clear
politics uh DeSantis is polling on
average 24 right now even if you're only
polling 24 percent
it's difficult to get away from running
when it will put you on the national
stage up against Trump which is a great
opportunity to get attention which can
backfire if Trump makes fun of you in a
way that's effective but gives you a ton
of national attention and you probably
to some degree think to yourself I mean
listen Nikki Haley announced and she's
polling what is she polling she's
polling three percent and uh you know
Rama Swami announced then he's polling
one percent I haven't announced anything
yet and I'm polling 24
I'm sure I can build that number if I
actually announce and run so on the one
hand that would be the argument that
makes it very difficult for you to say
I'm not going to run on the other hand
if you're patient it does seem logical
to me to think you know I'm pulling 24
but what's my ceiling is is most of the
you know Haley Pompeo Cheney is is all
of that just going to go to Trump who's
already over 50 percent
do I really have a shot here or do I
have a better shot at waiting until 2028
what might interfere with that
is that there is uncertainty you don't
know what will happen to your political
career between now and 2028 and so so
maybe it is difficult for DeSantis to
get away with from it I don't think that
it is a hundred percent that DeSantis
runs but I think it is the most likely
outcome at this time and from the people
I've spoken to in Florida who are sort
of like tangentially surrounding the
DeSantis Camp uh there is a lot of
confidence that the decision has already
been made by DeSantis that he's not
going back and that no polling collapse
short of going to zero is going to
dissuade him from running we'll watch it
and we'll follow it very closely
by now all of us know how creepy it is
to talk to a friend about something and
then get ads that are related when you
use a free email service from a big Tech
Corporation your emails are scanned even
if you're emailing your spouse or your
doctor which is why I recommend start
mail the email service that never scans
or analyzes your email our sponsor start
mail also lets you create unlimited
email address aliases so you don't even
have to give out your real email address
this protects you from spam and phishing
attacks phishing attacks are becoming
way more sophisticated with the rise of
chat GPT by the way start mail lets you
encrypt any email you send even if the
recipient isn't using encryption unlike
the big Tech email Services who store
even your deleted emails when you delete
an email and start mail it is gone
migrating from your current email
service to start mail is just a few
clicks so what are you waiting for stop
letting big Tech corporations spy on
your email my audience gets 50 off your
first year at startmail.com Pacman the
link is down below